in the last video we showed that the
squared error between some line y equals
MX plus B and each of these points each
of these n data points is this
expression right over here in this video
I'm really just going to algebraically
manipulate this expression so it's ready
for the calculus stage so that we can
actually optimize we can actually find
the M and B values that minimize this
value right over here so this is just
going to be a ton of algebraic
manipulation but I'll try to color code
it well so we don't get lost in the math
so let me just rewrite this expression
over here so this whole video is just
going to be rewriting this over and over
again just simplifying it a bit with
algebra so this first term right over
here Y 1 minus MX 1 plus B squared
that's going to be and we could write
this is all going to be the squared
error of the line so this first term
over here I'll keep it in blue is going
to be if we just expand it Y 1 squared Y
1 squared minus 2 times minus 2 times y
1 times M X 1 plus B plus MX MX 1 plus B
squared all I did is I just squared this
binomial right here you can imagine this
if this was a minus B it would be a
squared minus 2 a B plus B squared
that's all I did now I'll just have to
do that for each of the terms and each
term is only different by the X and the
y coordinates right over here so the
next term and I'll write it I'll go down
so that we can kind of combine like
terms so this term over here squared is
going to be Y 2 squared minus 2 times y
2 times M X 2 plus B plus M X 2 plus B
squared
same exact thing up here except now it
was with X 2 and Y 2 as opposed to x1
and y1 and then we're just going to keep
doing that n times we're just going to
keep doing it end time so we're going to
do it for the third X x3 y3 keep going
keep going all the way until we get to
this nth term over here and this nth
term over here when we square it is
going to be Y
N squared minus 2 y n times M xn plus B
plus M X n plus B squared now the next
thing I want to do is actually expand
these out a little bit more let's expand
these on little boards so let's actually
scroll down so this whole expression I'm
just going to rewrite it is the same
thing as and remember this is just a
squared error of the line so let me
rewrite this top line over here this top
line over here is y1 squared and then
I'm going to distribute this to y1 so
this is going to be this is going to be
minus 2 y 1m X 1 that's just that times
that minus 2 y 1 B minus 2 y 1 B and
then plus and now let's expand M x1 plus
B squared so that's going to be M
Squared x1 squared plus 2 2 times M x1
times B plus B squared all I did if this
was a plus B squared this is a squared
plus 2 a B plus B squared and we're just
gonna do that for each of these terms or
for each of these colors I guess you
could say so now let's move to the
second term so plus it's going to be the
same thing but instead of Y ones and X
ones it's going to be Y 2 s and X 2 s so
it is y 2 squared minus 2y 2m X 2 minus
2y to be plus M squared X 2 squared plus
2 times M X to be plus B squared and
we're going to keep doing this all the
way until we get the emptor m-- all the
way until we get all the way until we
get to the enth I guess color we should
say so this is going to be Y n squared
minus 2 y n let me minus 2 y n M X and
you don't even have to think you just
have to kind of substitute these with
ends now
we could actually look at this but it's
going to be the exact same thing m xn
minus 2 y n B plus M Squared X n squared
plus 2m X n B plus B squared so once
again this is just the squared error of
that line with n points between those
endpoints and the line y equals MX plus
B so let's see if we can simplify this
somehow and to do that to do that what
I'm going to do is I'm going to kind of
try to add up a bunch of these terms
here so if I were to add up if I were to
add up all of these terms right here if
I were to add up this column right over
there what do I get
well it's going to be Y it's going to be
Y 1 squared plus y 2 squared plus y all
the way to all the way to Y N squared
that's those terms right over there so
I'm going to have that and then I'm
going to have and then I'm going to have
minus you're going to you have this
common you have this common 2m amongst
all of these terms over here so let me
write that down
so then you have this 2m here 2m here
2m here so then you're going to have
like the parentheses around here so you
have these terms all added up then you
have minus 2m minus 2m times all of
these terms all of these terms so you
have actually let me color code it just
so you see what we're doing I want to be
very careful with the with this math so
that nothing seems too confusing
although this is really just algebraic
manipulation so if I add all of these up
I get y1 squared plus y2 squared all the
way to Y N squared I'll put some
parentheses around that and then to that
we have these common term we have this
minus 2m minus 2m minus 2m so we can
distribute those out and so this
actually I should actually write it like
this so we have a minus 2m times once we
distribute it out up here we're just
going to be left with a y1 x1
maybe I could call it an x1 y1 x1 y1
that's that over there with the 2m
factored out plus x2 let me do that in
another color I want to make this easy
to read
plus plus x2 y2 plus xn yn plus X and
well we're going to keep adding up we're
going to this n times all the way to
plus X n yn this last term over your Y
and X n same thing so that's that's the
sum so this stuff over here let me just
a new color the sum of all of this stuff
right over here is the same thing as
this term right over here and then we
have to sum this right over here and you
see again we can factor out we can
factor out here a minus to be out of all
of these terms so we have minus to be -
to be x times y 1 plus y 2 plus y 2 plus
all the way - all the way to yn all the
way to yn so this so this business so
these terms right over here these terms
right over here when you add them up
give you these terms or this term right
over there now let's just keep going and
then in the next video we're probably
going to run out of time in this one in
the next video I'll simplify this more
it'll actually clean up the algebra a
good bit so then the next term what is
this going to be same drill same drill
we have we can factor out an M Squared
so we have M squared times times x1
squared plus x2 squared plus all the way
which I want to color code them at least
color I forgot to color code these over
here plus x2 squared x2 squared plus all
the way to xn squared plus all the way
to xn squared let me color code these
this was a Y Y n squared and this over
here was a y2 squared so this is exactly
this so we've written so in this last
step we just did this thing over here
this thing over here is this thing right
over here and of course we have to add
it so I'll put a plus out front we're
almost done with this stage of the
simplification so over here we have a
common 2mb so let's put a plus 2m b
times once again X 1 X 1 plus X 2 plus X
2 plus all the way to xn all the way to
X all the way to xn so this term right
over here this term right over here is
the exact same thing is the exact same
thing as this term over here and then
finally we have a B squared in each of
these and how many of these B squares do
we do do we have well we have n of these
lines right this is the first line
second line and a bunch bunch bunch all
the way to the nth line so we have B
squared add it to itself n times so this
right over here
this right over here is just B squared n
time so we'll just write that as plus n
times B squared now does it look like
let me remind ourselves what we're this
is all about this is all just algebraic
manipulation of the squared error
between those end points between those
end points and the line y equals MX plus
B does it look like I've simplified it
much and I'm going to stop in this video
right now in the next video we're going
to take off right here and try to
simplify this thing